Welcome back.
We're on problem number
six, on page 670.
If the average of 6, 6, 12,
16, and x-- the average is
equal to x, what is
the value of x?
So if I were to average all
these numbers, I get x.
How do I average?
I add them up, I add up the
numbers, and I divide by the
number of numbers there are.
So there's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5
numbers, so I divide by that.
And they're saying that this
average is going to equal x.
So let's multiply
both sides by 5.
And I get 6 plus 6 plus 12 plus
16 plus x is equal to
20-- my brain is malfunctioning,
the average is
equal to x, right?
So I have to multiply
both sides by 5.
So I multiply both sides
by 5, I get 5x.
Right?
This is the average, and they
say the average is equal to x.
Multiply both sides by 5, you
get rid of the 5 in the
denominator here, you get 5x
on the right-hand side.
And what's the sum?
6 plus 6 is 12, 12 plus 12
is 24, 24 plus 16 is 40.
So we get 40 plus x
is equal to 5x.
Subtract x from both sides,
40 is equal to 4x.
Divide both sides by 4, you
get x is equal to 10.
And that is choice D.
Next problem.
Let me draw this triangle.
Let me try my best to
draw the triangle.
Looks something like that.
And then there's an altitude
right here, just
drop straight down.
And then they tell us that
this is a 90-- or
do they tell us?
My cousin who used my book drew
over it, so I'm not sure.
But I'm pretty sure they
tell us that this
is a 90 degree angle.
For the figure above, what
is the value of z?
So they say this is z, this
is y, this is 2y,
and this is 40 degrees.
So what is z?
So we know this is a 90 degree
angle, and we know that z plus
y plus 90 is equal to 180.
So if we know what y is,
we could figure out z.
And how can we figure out y?
Well we know that 2y-- if we
look at this right-hand
triangle-- we know that
2y plus 40 plus
90 is equal to 180.
Right?
So 2y plus 130 is
equal to 180.
2y is equal to 50 degrees.
y is equal to 25 degrees.
So this is 25 degrees.
I really wish I could read this
problem, I'm pretty sure
they drew in a little
perpindicular-- but anyway, we
might have been able
to address it
even if they didn't.
But if y is 25, then we know
that z plus 25 plus 90 is
equal to 180.
z plus 115 is equal to 180.
z is equal to-- subtract
115 from both sides,
what's 80 minus 15?
65.
The choice is C.
Next problem, problem
number eight.
A computer program randomly
selects a
positive 2 digit integer.
If the integer selected
is odd, twice
that integer is printed.
So odd, it prints
2 times integer.
If the integer is even, the
integer itself is printed.
So if it's even, it just
prints the integer.
So if it's an odd and you
multiply it by 2, it's
actually going to print an even
integer no matter what.
If the integer printed is 26,
which of the following could
have been the integer
selected?
So all we see is 26.
We just see 26.
So 26 could've been generated
one of two ways.
It could have been generated
by an even number that was
just kept the same.
Well, if it was an even number
that was kept the same and you
got 26, then we know that
the number is 26.
The number that generated
was 26.
The other possibility is it
could've been an odd number
that was doubled, right?
If it was an odd number that
was doubled, that means 2
times the odd number
is equal to 26.
So that means that the number
would have to be 13, right?
13 times odd-- sorry-- 2 times
odd-- these are the two
situations-- 2 times odd is
going to be equal to 26, in
which case odd is equal to 13.
Or 1 times even is going to be
equal to 26, it which case
even equals 26.
So the number generated could've
been 26 or it could
have been 13.
And those are choices 1
and 2, and that's C.
Next problem, problem
number nine.
They give you choice 52 in
that last problem just to
confuse you, to actually end
up doubling the 26, but we
know that the odd number was
doubled to get 26, so the
number generated would
have been 13.
Problem number nine.
How many seconds are there in
m minutes and s seconds?
Well, how many seconds
are there per minute?
Let's write this expression
as m minutes
plus s seconds, right?
Well, what does m equal
in terms of seconds?
Or how many seconds are
there per minute?
Well, we know that there are
60 seconds per m, right?
Or we could say that 60 seconds
is equal to 1m, right?
So if there's 60 seconds in 1m,
how many-- actually, I'm
confusing the issue, let
me write it this way.
m minutes, right?
There's m minutes.
How many seconds are
there per minute?
Let me start over, because
I think I confused
you a little bit.
So I'm going to write--
actually, let me write it
without m and s, that's what
confusing me as well.
Let's say I have x minutes plus
y seconds, and I want to
convert it all into seconds.
Well, we know that there are 60
seconds per minute, right?
So if we want to convert a
minute to seconds, we write x
minutes times 60 seconds per
minute plus y seconds.
And so the minutes will cancel
out, and so you're left with
60 times x-- and this is
something that you'll learn in
physics class, that you can
treat units just like you
would treat variables, and
they'll cancel out similarly.
So you'd get 60x-- right, the
minutes have canceled out--
let me switch colors--
you'll get 60 times x
seconds, plus y seconds.
So your total number of
seconds is 60x plus y.
And in the problem though, in
minutes they didn't say x,
they said m, so x is
m, and then y is s.
So 60m plus s, so
that's choice A.
And this might have been a
little confusing, let me do it
a simpler way, or maybe a more
intuitive way for you.
There's m minutes, how many
seconds are in m minutes?
Think about it.
If there is-- if I'm talking
about 2 minutes, there's 60
seconds per minute, so if I
said 2 minutes, I would
multiply 2 times 60, and I
would get to 120 seconds.
If it was 5 minutes, I would
multiply 5 times 60, and get
to 300 seconds.
So if I have m minutes,
I'll multiply 60 times
m to get 60m seconds.
And of course, they said m
minutes plus s seconds.
So now I have 60m seconds,
plus these s seconds.
So my total number of seconds
is 60m plus s.
This is a more intuitive
way, maybe.
You should always try out
numbers, and hopefully it'll
make a little bit more sense.
The way I did it previously is
how you would do it in physics
class, where you would actually
cancel out the units
and make sure you're doing
it the right way.
See you in the next video.